Eigenvectors and eigenvalues is one of
those topics that a lot of students find
particularly unintuitive. Questions
like, why are we doing this and what
does this actually mean? Are too often
left just floating away in an unanswered
sea of computations.
And as I've put out the videos of the
series, a lot of you have commented
about looking forward to visualizing
this topic in particular. I suspect that
the reason for this is not so much that
eigen things are particularly
complicated or poorly explained. In
fact, it's comparatively straightforward
and I think most books do a fine job
explaining it. The issue is that it only
really makes sense if you have a solid
visual understanding for many of the
topics that precede it.
Most important here is that you know how
to think about matrices as linear
transformations. But you also need to be
comfortable with things like
determinants, linear systems of
equations, and change of basis.
Confusion about eigen stuff usually has
more to do with a shaky foundation in
one of these topics than it does with
eigenvectors and eigenvalues themselves.
To start, consider some linear
transformation in two dimensions, like
the one shown here.
It moves the basis vector I hat to the
coordinates 3 0 and J hat to 1 2.
So, it's represented with a matrix whose
columns are 3 0 and 1 2.
Focus in on what it does to one
particular vector and think about the
span of that vector, the line passing
through its origin and its tip.
Most vectors are going to get knocked
off their span during the
transformation. I mean, it would seem
pretty coincidental if the place where
the vector landed also happened to be
somewhere on that line.
But some special vectors remain on their
own span, meaning the effect that the
matrix has on such a vector is just to
stretch it or squish it like a scalar.
For this specific example, the basis
vector I hat is one such special vector.
The span of I hat is the x-axis, and
from the first column of the matrix, we
can see that I hat moves over to three
times itself, still on that x-axis.
What's more, because of the way linear
transformations work, any other vector
on the x-axis is also just stretched by
a factor of three, and hence remains on
its own span.
A slightly sneakier vector that remains
on its own span during this
transformation is -1, 1.
It ends up getting stretched by a factor
of two.
And again, linearity is going to imply
that any other vector on the diagonal
line spanned by this guy is just going
to get stretched out by a factor of two.
And for this transformation, those are
all the vectors with this special
property of staying on their span. Those
on the x-axis getting stretched out by a
factor of three, and those on this
diagonal line getting stretched by a
factor of two.
Any other vector is going to get rotated
somewhat during the transformation,
knocked off the line that it spans.
As you might have guessed by now, these
special vectors are called the
eigenvectors of the transformation. And
each eigenvector has associated with it
what's called an eigenvalue, which is
just the factor by which it's stretched
or squished during the transformation.
Of course, there's nothing special about
stretching versus squishing, or the fact
that these eigenvalues happen to be
positive. In another example, you could
have an eigenvector with eigenvalue
-1/2, meaning that the vector gets
flipped and squished by a factor of 1/2.
But the important part here is that it
stays on the line that it spans out
without getting rotated off of it.
For a glimpse of why this might be a
useful thing to think about, consider
some three-dimensional rotation.
If you can find an eigenvector for that
rotation, a vector that remains on its
own span, what you have found is the
axis of rotation.
And it's much easier to think about a 3D
rotation in terms of some axis of
rotation and an angle by which it's
rotating, rather than thinking about the
full 3 by 3 matrix associated with that
transformation.
In this case, by the way, the
corresponding eigenvalue would have to
be one, since rotations never stretch or
squish anything. So, the length of the
vector would remain the same.
This pattern shows up a lot in linear
algebra. With any linear transformation
described by a matrix, you could
understand what it's doing by reading
off the columns of this matrix as the
landing spots for basis vectors. But
often a better way to get at the heart
of what the linear transformation
actually does, less dependent on your
particular coordinate system, is to find
the eigenvectors and eigenvalues.
I won't cover the full details on
methods for computing eigenvectors and
eigenvalues here, but I'll try to give
an overview of the computational ideas
that are most important for a conceptual
understanding.
Symbolically, here's what the idea of an
eigenvector looks like.
A is the matrix representing some
transformation, with V as the
eigenvector, and lambda is a number,
namely the corresponding eigenvalue.
What this expression is saying is that
the matrix-vector product A * V gives
the same result as just scaling the
eigenvector v by some value lambda.
So, finding the eigenvectors and their
eigenvalues of a matrix A comes down to
finding the values of v and lambda that
make this expression true.
It's a little awkward to work with at
first because that left-hand side
represents matrix vector multiplication,
but the right-hand side here is scalar
vector multiplication. So, let's start
by rewriting that right-hand side as
some kind of matrix vector
multiplication using a matrix which has
the effect of scaling any vector by a
factor of lambda.
The columns of such a matrix will
represent what happens to each basis
vector, and each basis vector is simply
multiplied by lambda, so this matrix
will have the number lambda down the
diagonal with zeros everywhere else.
The common way to write this guy is to
factor that lambda out and write it as
lambda times I, where I is the identity
matrix with ones down the diagonal.
With both sides looking like matrix
vector multiplication, we can subtract
off that right-hand side and factor out
the v.
So, what we now have is a new matrix A
minus lambda times the identity, and
we're looking for a vector v such that
this new matrix times v gives the zero
vector.
Now, this will always be true if v
itself is the zero vector, but that's
boring. What we want is a non-zero
eigenvector.
And if you watch chapter five and six,
you'll know that the only way it's
possible for the product of a matrix
with a non-zero vector to become zero is
if the transformation associated with
that matrix squishes space into a lower
dimension.
And that squishification corresponds to
a zero determinant for the matrix.
To be concrete, let's say your matrix A
has columns 2 1 and 2 3, and think about
subtracting off a variable amount lambda
from each diagonal entry.
Now imagine tweaking lambda, turning a
knob to change its value.
As that value of lambda changes, the
matrix itself changes, and so the
determinant of the matrix changes.
The goal here is to find a value of
lambda that will make this determinant
zero, meaning the tweaked transformation
squishes space into a lower dimension.
In this case, the sweet spot comes when
lambda equals 1.
Of course, if we had chosen some other
matrix, the eigenvalue might not
necessarily be 1. The sweet spot might
be hit at some other value of lambda.
So, this is kind of a lot, but let's
unravel what this is saying. When lambda
equals 1, the matrix A minus lambda
times the identity squishes space onto a
line.
That means there's a non-zero vector V
such that A minus lambda times the
identity times V equals the zero vector.
And remember, the reason we care about
that is because it means A times V
equals lambda times V.
Which you can read off as saying that
the vector V is an eigenvector of A,
staying on its own span during the
transformation A.
In this example, the corresponding
eigenvalue is 1. So, V would actually
just stay fixed in place.
Pause and ponder if you need to make
sure that that line of reasoning feels
good.
This is the kind of thing I mentioned in
the introduction. If you didn't have a
solid grasp of determinants and why they
relate to linear systems of equations
having non-zero solutions, an expression
like this would feel completely out of
the blue.
To see this in action, let's revisit the
example from the start with a matrix
whose columns are 3 0 and 1 2.
To find if a value lambda is an eigen
value, subtract it from the diagonals of
this matrix and compute the determinant.
Doing this, we get a certain quadratic
polynomial in lambda, 3 - lambda * 2 -
lambda.
Since lambda can only be an eigen value
if this determinant happens to be zero,
you can conclude that the only possible
eigen values are lambda equals 2 and
lambda equals 3.
To figure out what the eigen vectors are
that actually have one of these eigen
values, say lambda equals 2,
plug in that value of lambda to the
matrix
and then solve for which vectors this
diagonally altered matrix sends to zero.
If you computed this the way you would
any other linear system, you'd see that
the solutions are all the vectors on the
diagonal line spanned by -1, 1.
This corresponds to the fact that the
unaltered matrix 3 0 1 2 has the effect
of stretching all those vectors by a
factor of 2.
Now, a 2D transformation doesn't have to
have eigen vectors. For example,
consider a rotation by 90°. This doesn't
have any eigen vectors since it rotates
every vector off of its own span.
If you actually try computing the eigen
values of a rotation like this, notice
what happens.
Its matrix has columns 0 1 and -1, 0.
Subtract off lambda from the diagonal
elements and look for when the
determinant is zero.
In this case, you get the polynomial
lambda squared + 1.
The only roots of that polynomial are
the imaginary numbers I and -I.
The fact that there are no real number
solutions indicates that there are no
eigen vectors.
Another pretty interesting example worth
holding in the back of your mind is a
shear.
This fixes I hat in place and moves J
hat one over. So, its matrix has columns
1 0 and 1 1.
All of the vectors on the x-axis are
eigen vectors with eigen value one since
they remain fixed in place.
In fact, these are the only eigen
vectors.
When you subtract off lambda from the
diagonals and compute the determinant,
what you get is 1 - lambda squared.
And the only root of this expression is
lambda equals one.
This lines up with what we see
geometrically, that all of the eigen
vectors have eigen value one.
Keep in mind though, it's also possible
to have just one eigen value,
but with more than just a line full of
eigen vectors.
A simple example is a matrix that scales
everything by two.
The only eigen value is two, but every
vector in the plane gets to be an eigen
vector with that eigen value.
Now is another good time to pause and
ponder some of this before I move on to
the last topic.
I want to finish off here with the idea
of an eigen basis, which relies heavily
on ideas from the last video.
Take a look at what happens if our basis
vectors just so happen to be eigen
vectors.
For example, maybe I hat is scaled by -1
and J hat is scaled by two.
Writing their new coordinates as the
columns of a matrix, notice that those
scalar multiples, -1 and 2, which are
the eigen values of i hat and j hat, sit
on the diagonal of our matrix, and every
other entry is a zero.
Anytime a matrix has zeros everywhere
other than the diagonal, it's called,
reasonably enough, a diagonal matrix.
And the way to interpret this is that
all the basis vectors are eigen vectors,
with the diagonal entries of this matrix
being their eigen values.
There are a lot of things that make
diagonal matrices much nicer to work
with.
One big one is that it's easier to
compute what will happen if you multiply
this matrix by itself a whole bunch of
times.
Since all one of these matrices does is
scale each basis vector by some eigen
value, applying that matrix many times,
say 100 times, is just going to
correspond to scaling each basis vector
by the 100th power of the corresponding
eigen value.
In contrast, try computing the 100th
power of a non-diagonal matrix. Really,
try it for a moment. It's a nightmare.
Of course, you'll rarely be so lucky as
to have your basis vectors also be eigen
vectors.
But, if your transformation has a lot of
eigen vectors, like the one from the
start of this video, enough so that you
can choose a set that spans the full
space,
then you could change your coordinate
system so that these eigen vectors are
your basis vectors.
I talked about change of basis last
video, but I'll go through a super quick
reminder here of how to express a
transformation currently written in our
coordinate system into a different
system.
Take the coordinates of the vectors that
you want to use as a new basis, which in
this case means our two eigen vectors.
Then make those coordinates the columns
of a matrix, known as the change of
basis matrix.
When you sandwich the original
transformation, putting the change of
basis matrix on its right and the
inverse of the change of basis matrix on
its left, the result will be a matrix
representing that same transformation,
but from the perspective of the new
basis vectors coordinate system.
The whole point of doing this with
eigenvectors is that this new matrix is
guaranteed to be diagonal with its
corresponding eigenvalues down that
diagonal. This is because it represents
working in a coordinate system where
what happens to the basis vectors is
that they get scaled during the
transformation.
A set of basis vectors, which are also
eigenvectors, is called, again,
reasonably enough, an eigenbasis.
So, if, for example, you needed to
compute the 100th power of this matrix,
it would be much easier to change to an
eigenbasis, compute the 100th power in
that system, then convert back to our
standard system.
You can't do this with all
transformations. A shear, for example,
doesn't have enough eigenvectors to span
the full space.
But if you can find an eigenbasis, it
makes matrix operations really lovely.
For those of you willing to work through
a pretty neat puzzle to see what this
looks like in action and how it can be
used to produce some surprising results,
I'll leave up a prompt here on the
screen. It takes a bit of work, but I
think you'll enjoy it.
The next and final video of this series
is going to be on abstract vector
spaces. See you then.